ثلاث لقاءات جماعه المغرب واسبانيا في
السابق كانت كلها في الاطار الرسمي في عام
1961 انتقل منتخبان لحساب تصفيات كاس
العالم في مباراتين لتحديد المتاهل
لمونديال تشيلي فاز فيما المنتخب الاسباني
في مجموعه المواجهتين بنتيجه اربع اهداف
مقابل هدفين اللقاء الثالث جمع المنتخب في
مونديال روسيا 2018 وانتهى بالتعادل
الايجابي بهدفين لمثلهما في كاس العالم
الحالي حقق المنتخب المغربي الفوز في
مبارتين وتعادل في واحده متصدر مجموعته
فيما تاهل المنتخب الاسباني بصعوبه بعد
تحقيقه لفوز واحد مقابل تعادل وخساره
مفاجاه امام اليابان بهدفين مقابل هدف
سجل المنتخب المغربي في كاس العالم الحالي
اربعه اهداف وتلقى هدفا واحدا فيما سجل
المنتخب الاسباني 9 اهداف وتلقى ثلاثه
اهداف